I'll play in English for the person he
was asking d6 is a move I'll play
neither 3 in d4 sometime flat goes for
f5 but probably not in this case I'll
have a space advantage Bishop each year
costly it's like a Marathi mine setup
miracle of realism welcome I think I
want to avoid trades because blacks a
bit confined my pawns control space
complete development in each one typical
move Queen d2
yeah lots of improving moves still still
to make not sure why black fiend head of
the night maybe to play f5 f5 is
interesting I could ignore it I could do
something about it
Queen d5 ideas what else to do rook d1
looks natural I'll just leave the
tension if takes I'll probably take with
Knights as some idea of c5 Bishop c4 can
be nice and also this pawn is pinned it
was pinned to the bishop now it's not
plate 94 offering a trade trying to
activate take with Queen Bishop f6
coming okay I'll take with Bishop 95
Horatio yeah 20 20 K is a big number
would not have imagined getting to this
point like two years ago when I first
started streaming it takes really want
to take not sure of Queen Queen here
looks interesting it's kind of stuck
there's Bishop f8
maybe c5 it's weird to leave the Queen
aligned with blacks bishop but there's
there's only one legal night move and I
want exploit the fat my rook is aligned
with blacks queen and this is also oh
this is so juicy time to drink some
juice Bishop e7 has only moved that
really defends but it hangs me than one
oh that move defends I could vote s
gambit have a beautiful boat s gambit
yesterday it's only a temporary vote s
candids unless I make it not temporary I
could play f4 oh man f4 I can't resist I
can't resist a fort I'm leaving the
Knights at a very similar position
yesterday
my knight was doing work I'm letting
black run away with a queen with the
Queen if 27 I could take Kim GA then I
win the Queen back okay I'm having fun
like the rest of the pieces I have
they're all having potential I get this
I do this and then this and then this
and then so many arrows all over the
place play half five first well I think
I'll play this first it's hard for the
King to find safety
but I am down a queen down queen for a
night wait do I have a beautiful move
oh my gosh I almost have a beautiful
move it's so close to working or kz6
wrote a c6 King takes here here it's
when he escaped g4g forking takes f for
VAR f 1o is it g5 mate no g5 makes it
illegal because the Queen mmm not seeing
it I could play a 5x5 I have to analyze
that afterwards I got excited there for
a moment but this is nice I act the
bishop you can take the Knights but
that's a move let's I don't a flag take
this way
takes it's so complicated there should
have seven ideas play this
what is going on
just trade and do this rook is hanging
but I don't want to take it piece is so
beautiful and to take this way is a
queen trapped the Queen's almost trapped
play this move
oh my nights hanging no didn't take it
oh yeah play this move all my nights
still hanging I'm threatening maiden to
wait this is me right now I win the
Queen Bishop f1 in the end
No
I could have been so beautiful
dirty flower coming dirty flag let's go
what the game I didn't deserve to win
that but maybe I did I don't know mixed
emotions analysis board I really wanted
okay so I got excited for a moment they
just show this where was it it was after
Bishop g7 I wanted to take here and I
was calculating amazing line G for King
takes F for rook F 1 I'm controlling all
these squares King G 5 rook F 5 King h6
and then mates the problem is a g4 is
illegal because the Queen pins upon so I
didn't see me here it's so close
cuz after a rookie one the King has to
go to f5 but if I don't have g4 hmm
Bishop I don't think there's anything a
five first I'm gonna check with stock
fish stock fish is confused and lazy
okay
White's losing so going back to this
position
I mean f4 it was just it was too much
fun okay maybe I'll put this on youtube
botas gambit part 2 or part 3 I've lost
count
anyway this is dedicated to bow ties
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
future